alors qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de voir
quand même toutes les génération
confondu Salvator vous dire il est beau
comme un dieu c'est c'est un chanteur de
charme mais pas du tout au contraire je
suis l'Éternel timide bon j'étais très
sensible au charmes féminin bien sûr
mais mon but n'a jamais été la la
séduction directe si je peux dire mais
c'est à votre corps défendant
oui disonsle comme ça mais ça vous
rajunie d'entendre justement tout cela
vous êtes l'éternel jeune homme vous
l'avez entend à mes 60 ans il y a un
dessinateur belge pierre Croll qui m'a
fait un dessin donc il m'a dessiné me
penchant devant un monsieur barbu d'un
enfin d'un âge moyen et la légende c'est
vous permettez monsieur que j'emprend
votre
mère la chanson m'a rattrapé mais c'est
drôle c'est très drôle quoi qu'il en
soit votre épouse qui parle de façon
très exceptionnelle a aussi un certain
humour hein beaucoup d'humour beaucoup
de philosophie comme elle l'a dit là
elle a pas arrêté de faire la part des
choses intelligemment ouais pas jalouse
disons qu'elle elle a surpassé ce ce
genre de sentiment mais naturellement et
je le comprends elle est passée par là
aussi bien sûr elle a toujours été voilà
tous les deux votre point
d'ancrage mon équilibre oui certainement
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance de l'avoir
aussi pour l'éducation de mes deux fils
puisque moi quand je rentrais de
tourné les bras chargés de cadeaux pour
me faire pardonner comme le le disait ma
sœur Giovanna je ne me je ne m'occupais
pas vraiment des des bulletin des
résultats scolaires j'essayais de de de
me faire pardonner mon absence par par
des largesses de tendresse bien sûr mais
matériel il y a des moments où sans
doute ils ont eu besoin de moi que ce
soit que ce soit so mes deux fils ou ma
fille bien sûr vous j'ai toujours été le
père absent quoi c'est un vraiment un de
mes seuls regrets à 23 ans finalement
vous vous êtes retrouvé tuteur vrai
tuteur ou chef de famille chef de
famille oui il y a pas de document
officiel je trouvais normal de de
prendre d'essayer de prendre le relais
et j'ai essayé comme disait Giovanna de
déléguer
j'essayé de de cétait tout jeune à 23
ans oui j'avais fait appel à une
préceptrice et puis il y avait chez mes
sœurs une conscience que cette autorité
qu'on essay de leur imposer n'était pas
la vraie celle de mon père qui n'était
plus là malheureusement donc il y avait
un refus de leur part bien sûr votre
Père qui est donc disparu tragiquement
oui il est il est disparu par noyade en
Sicile devant justement toute la famille
sauf moi moi j'étais j'étais à biarit ce
jour-là c'était le le 7 août
66 et donc on j'ai reçu un coup de fil
pour me dire ton père n'est plus là et
en fait je lui je lui avais offert son
son rêve c'était de revenir au pays en
vainqueur si je peux dire alors qu'il
était parti parce que le pays ne pouvait
plus le nourrir puisti à l'époque oui et
il est revenu et il il avait fait un un
restaurant un club restaurant h la note
qui qui est le titre italien de de mes
chansons la nuit et il n'a même pas pu
assister à l'inauguration puis qu'il il
est parti
avant voilà et ma mère ma mère qui qui
qui avait toujours vécu un pas en
arrière si je peux dire elle était la
Sicilienne typique ma mère nous a donné
toute la
tendresse dont nous avions besoin mais à
un moment donné il était un peu dépassé
par les événements c'était vous l'aîné
et oui et donc l'aîné est celui qui
avait réussi à ce moment-là à 23 ans oui
j'étais c'est vous qui preniez j'étais
responsable de l'éducation de mes frères
et sœurs matériellement je pouvais
l'assumer donc je l'ai fait avec grand
plaisir mais encore une fois ils avaient
besoin d' d'une vraie présence et ça je
nai je n'ai pas pu malheureusement ça
reste une blessure pour vous cela mais
bien sûr chanter ça a toujours été le
rêve pour moi qui qui est devenu réalité
donc donné peut-être qu'on attendait de
moi que je chante moins et que je sois
plus présent et ça je je n'ai pas eu la
force de le faire peut-être c'était
peut-être une question de force mais
j'étais très jeune aussi et en même
temps ce que vous apportiez c'est bien
parce que vous étiez oui c'est un cercle
pas vicieux mais béni béni fallait je
continue à assumer matériellement il
fallait que j'alimente donc le juste
milieu était très difficile à à trouver
il il est parti beaucoup trop tôt mais
pendant 3 ans il a il a quand même vu ce
qui m'était arrivé quoi il a il l'a vécu
avec moi c'est formidable cette Archie
est absolument magnifique c'est le le
seul vrai manager que j'ai eu parce que
il s'occupait de tout je lui chantais
mes chansons en premier il donnait son
avis il a signé des autographes pour
vous il a fait partie ili il a signé
pour lui il signait papa papa Adamo il
signait ah oui oui parce que des parents
le faisaient pour leurs enfants jeun
qui m'a raconté C à lui signé il signé
pour lui c'était lui la la star d'une
certaine façon c'est ce que je dis dans
la chanson que je lui est dédié pour moi
c'est un guide la complicité qu' AV avec
le père est difficile à remplacer
vraiment mais on sent qu'elle n'a pas
été remplacé elle ne peut pas l'être de
toute façon mais elle elle est présente
il vous accompagne il est là quand j'ai
je suis en j'ai un problème j'en suis
toujours à me dire qu'is dit core est
fait mon père de votre enfance quel est
le le plus beau souvenir que vous gardez
en
mémoire il y a des des souvenirs qui
sont
palpables par exemple quand je je
dormais à côté de ma maman pendant que
notre père était déjà en
Belgique pour chercher le travail et le
logement il y a un
ma joue sur la joue de ma mère qui est
un
souvenir si je m'y consentre je le
ressens encore aujourd'hui oui
absolument voil voilà
voilà exactement c'est ça qui resta
gravé en vous ce contact
jeanville cette insouciance et cette
confiance qu'on peut avoir à C âge là
quand vous étiez justement enfant dans
votre famille donc avec votre papa
mineur vous rêviez à quoi à 15 ans
c'était le football et puis j'ai j'ai
commencé à chanter mais la chanson
j'osais pas trop y croire puisque je
m'étais fait mettre à la porte de la
chorale à 14 ans parce que j'avais mal
mué donc c'est vrai que j'ai toujours
dit que j'étais un un ténor sicilien qui
est allé s'enrumer dans les brumes du
nord et qui a gardé la la
voix mais avec l'envie de sortir des
corons c'était des des des baragements
comme l'a dit Giovanna ma sœur et c'est
une école de
vie qui laisse des traces indélébiles et
et d'une certaine façon
je je trouve bien d'être passé par là
parce que ça m'a laissé en contact avec
certaines vraies valeurs c'est pas c'est
solus qui disait qu' ne sera jamais un
nouveau riche mais toujours un ancien
pauvre rester un ancien pauvre ça veut
dire ne pas pouvoir aussi profiter
complètement de ce qu'on a a gagné ça
veut dire avoir un certain respect et et
ne pas ne pas gaspiller tout simplement
ouais ça c'est ne pas non plus être au
cant àire voilà surtout rester digne et
discret quoi qu'il en soit vous savez
toujours d'où vous venez c'est quelque
chose qui est resté présent en vous
oui bien sûr c'est une petite lueur qui
qui si jamais il m'arrivait de d'être en
danger de l'oublier ne fus qu'un instant
PAP la la lueur elle est là quoi c'est
pour ça que vous êtes engagé aussi à un
moment donné dans l'UNICEF puisque vous
avez été l'ambassadeur et vous l'êtes
toujours je le suis toujours et c'est
vrai que l'UNICEF m'a m'a sollicité en
80 13 c'est pile à 50 ans c'était l'âge
où je me posais des questions par
rapport à à mon
utilité et elle m'attendit une perche
qui m'a qui m'a permis de
retrouver en partie une bonne conscience
ça veut dire qu'on peut avoir mauvaise
conscience de réussir on peut oui on
peut être mal à l'aise avec la réite oui
il m'est arrivé dans certains pays
d'aller chanter dans des palaces et et
de voir des des enfants en haayon sur
les marches des palais où j'allais
chanter et et de rentrer chez moi avec
un nœud dans la la gorge et complètement
impuissant et comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure l'UNICEF m'a donné une façon
de de me déculpabiliser voilà qu'est-ce
qu'on vous demande le plus quelle est la
chanson qu'on vous demande le plus c'est
toujours tombe la neige 300 version de
tombe la neige he au Japon il y en a
plus de plus de 500 versions c'est tous
les ans c'est un peu comme le Petit Papa
Noël en plus vous chantez en combien de
langues je chante en plus de langues que
je ne
parle j'ai même chanté dans des langues
comme le coréen le Turc le japonais que
je baraguine mais que je ne parle pas ça
donne quoi Tom BL neige en
japonais
la première fois que je l'ai chanté en
public un moment donné la salle éclaté
de rire j'ai j ce que j'avais prononcé
de
travers en plus il sont très on jamais
vouu dire
[Applaudissements]
vraimenton m en
arméené en je connais juste le
départ pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Ina mire Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche